OG fire the Fire OG
this show is brought to you by indochino
they are Reinventing men's fashion and
have a deal too good to pass up right
now our listeners get any premium suit
for just 3.99 that's 50 that's up to 50
off at indochino.com when you enter
promo code church at checkout plus
shipping is free that's indochino.com
enter the church at checkout and
shipping is free
the show is also brought to you by me
undies
go to meanddies.com Joey right now to
save 20 off of your first order and
shipping is always free in the US and
Canada and you can save up to eight
dollars a pair with the Mandy
subscription plan me and these makes the
most comfortable underwear in the world
to me on these.com Joey to save 20 off
of your first order and go to audit.com
and use code word church to save 10 off
all their amazing optimization products
like Alpha Brain new moves from taking a
swim tech support
kick that [__] meal away it's Monday
night [__]
a little Spanish music for you [__] is
that get your fueled up goalie let me
see you do a little wiggle oh [__]
[Laughter]
holy [__]
the church what's happening now
Monday July 18th the day the devil was
buried at Sea
we got Uncle Ed Suarez we got Lee syat
the flying Jew
goalie take that [__] Lee
that's all I'm great sitting down this
is a [__] Jam I'm telling you this is
too much these are Puerto Ricans at
their best right here what's going on
Tarzan good to have you on here uh
thanks for having me good to see you I
haven't seen you in a while yeah yeah at
Suarez manager of the year three years
in a Rowan [__] the UFC with you [__]
nuts all the famous
what's happening oh man just on the
grind man been working a lot a lot of
stuff going on a lot of stuff a lot all
good stuff man
you know it's a lot of good stuff
it's funny because whenever I call you
it's because
I think about like
five years ago we went to a way and
maybe six years ago in a Wayne
and that for the Wayne there was a
comedy show yeah and after the comedy
show you were like The Last Man Standing
when I walked around the casino we don't
do nothing we don't bother nobody yeah
I'm like what are you guys doing you're
like you're not going to go up to my
room and this is sleep and the other
guy's sleeping like go [__] come up
to my room let's go on the computer
whatever we came into the room I think
we ate some cashews and we got to a
conversation about fatherhood yeah and
you just were just telling me about
you know your life is this MMA stuff but
your life your two girls like you just
went off on the two girls and you like
going to Colorado and going skiing and
that's when I think about my memories in
Colorado all those years I think about
going to ski at 9 30 in the morning
going to like a mid-level range yeah and
the first the first run of the day you
know you're like
let's see what happens all of a sudden
something happens your timing is off and
you end up falling down
and as you're wiping the snow off here
and picking up your pole you look to
your right and there's 16 kids
coming down one button on each other Lee
and then doing 90 miles an hour with a
[__] instructor next to them and
they're like Jesus and you're like
I feel like such a [__] loser right
now these little kids you know and then
you figure you figure out that they're
Senator gravity gravity oh yeah but you
were just telling me all this and at
that time let me tell you something I
was just starting to get my life
together me and my wife had just got
married
you know I was older I wasn't thinking
of kids whatsoever I'm looking at you
and I'm like finally I bump into a
parent that's genuinely happy that he
put his time in her daughters and now
it's it's blossoming you know what I'm
saying
and I always think of that an awesome
one day my wife tells me she's pregnant
and all of a sudden my wife tells me
she's having a little girl and all of a
sudden boom this little [__] girl
pops out
and you as a gorilla don't know how to
really act around this little princess
but you have to go down to her level you
have to
part of my day now is comedy and I love
doing comedy and [__] I love doing the
podcast and I like going to meetings but
the other part of my day is being a dad
to this little future [__] monster
you know what I'm saying though
you know when you have to put the time
in I walk her to school I make sure I'm
there to pick her up from school just
little things you know what I'm saying
those that's what makes the difference
at night
I like to go in and talk to him in
Spanish and tell her God's watching her
and all this [__] don't [__] around in
here tonight
do you really
it's the world to me I go on and I say
after her mother reads the book and the
whole thing I give it like a half hour I
hear in there throwing [__] and [__]
having a one-woman show and talking to
myself and [__]
so I go in there she basically she's
asleep
and I wait a minute like a wiz mercy and
I don't hear nothing and all I gotta do
is give it a minute and she'll giggle by
herself like she starts giggling and I
just start talking to her English and I
just talked her in Spanish
and that's it on the way out like I
gotta go to work and then oh yeah no
matter how much I try to talk to her she
won't say nothing to me but on the way
out the door she'll say I love you too
Daddy
that's all you need that's yes that's as
good as it gets when you have a daughter
that's as good as the world [__] gets
oh yeah so I I seldom think of you when
I'm uh getting my fatherly
I know what you call it it's like a
bliss like you get a moment yeah I mean
yeah it's great it's you you'll have a
lot of those moments you know I mean I I
could tell you the the most recent
moment was dropping
uh the oldest one off at college man
that was that was one of the hardest
things I ever had to do in my life man
it was I didn't think it was going to be
that big of a deal I travel all the time
no big deal but then you know we drive
to Colorado we had a great time we went
river rafting we stayed in Vail her and
I and then dropped her off and then you
know
um my wife and uh my wife my daughter
and my wife's mom stayed there and and I
was just like you know what the drive
was so good coming back from uh driving
in I said you know what I'm just gonna
drive the car back because we were just
going to ship the car back so then I'd
take the car and uh so I was going to
leave a day earlier and then the night
we were gonna leave her at the college
man you know I'm thinking you know I
travel all the time I'm always away but
realizing that you're leaving your
daughter at school was a heavy man that
was a heavy [__] College yeah College
she's starting her sophomore year now in
college
and once your head explodes yeah because
you see him that little young I'm seeing
people on Facebook that I know on my
block that were little kids yeah one kid
in particular used to have a dog and he
used to throw rocks and the dog would
pick up the [__] rocks he had no
teeth left now he's like a dentist
laughs
but it's uh
as a dad like yeah you got you can have
a sign and they could be dirty and they
can throw rocks and [__] and break
windows and be the toughest kid on the
Block and yeah you get some little
respect from that [__] as a dad you know
and if they have a wild little boy
but there's nothing like having a little
girl to [__] pull back your reins and
make you really sit down and go Jesus
yeah Jesus what the [__] do I get into
it's like I told you earlier
I know if it's the antibiotics for the
reefer I smoked to Lee in the afternoon
I had to go home and take a nap dog yeah
and my wife came and she goes do you
want to eat I shouldn't my wife didn't
even know there was a podcast tonight
if she wouldn't have woke me up I would
have still been [__] past that
[Laughter]
my wife open the door do you want to eat
like oh yeah I'll be right in there and
there's my wife tearing her back Mercy
slipped right behind
and the cutest little [__] dresses
just started talking to me and she
wouldn't shut the [__] up she just
wouldn't and she kept looking me in the
eye and telling me the story like all
enthusiastic like yeah the Chinese dude
and all this [__] and I'm like what are
you say you know
then they say come follow me Daddy
nobody's ever told me to follow them and
nine out of ten times I ain't gonna
[__] follow you okay when she tells
me follow me Daddy I can't [__] be
right you're right there
you're right there your foot behind that
attention because I know I don't want to
even get the wrath of that [__]
that's yeah you know your kids will make
you do things you never thought you
would do
I used to do those Christmas movies with
Dean Kane and he wouldn't shut the [__]
up about this kid and I'd want to
[__] strangle like I'm like Superman
I want a [__] strangle he wouldn't
shut the [__] up by this boy he was
telling me that he'd take the gum out of
his kid's mouth and put in his [__]
mouth and just do crazy [__] you know
what I'm saying like at night he'd ask
the kid did you [__] him did you brush
your teeth then why did him come in your
mouth give me a [__] gum you know
just and he'd go you know you do
anything for your child and you see all
these TV shows and you see all these
parental dilemmas
and you really really really can't make
a judgment call until you have children
like I didn't know that I thought that
you could intervene like you were an
expert on parenting you know dick
know that child's in front of you yeah
they don't come with a man yeah you have
views on how to raise a child from how
you were raised and how you don't want
to be raised and what things you took
from your parents to raise your child
but at the same time
it doesn't come into effect
like couple weeks ago the band with the
[__] kid
your thought process is completely
different the gorilla oh yeah yeah
Chicago whatever yeah where they grab
the kids when you're 19 and somebody
tells you about a three-year-old falling
in a [__] thing with a gorilla when
you're 19 that's like talking about you
know
shoot the [__] kid whatever you would
say that stupidity you know but your
whole thing perspective changes yeah of
course what was I watching yesterday I
mean it's horrible that they had to kill
the gorilla but what what what are you
gonna do not do you know what I mean
well you know nobody wins in that
situation but just the perspective of it
you really can't you think you sit there
for a second and go I go to the LA Zoo
yeah what if my [__] daughter falls
into the [__] mouth whatever the hell
they call it that gorilla picks her up
right and then people are saying you're
like you know you know then the parent
should have been more uh you know uh
attention paying attention but but then
again it's like I mean it's a it's not
the kid's fault listen man again you're
sitting well the problem that we have
and I've been talking about on stage
until a society is that [__] cell
phone yeah
you know nine out of ten when something
happens with your child what's your
first reaction I turned my back for a
minute
yeah well now you're turning you back
for eight minutes a day because you're
looking at that [__] Amendment they
put up about Clinton's wife or
you know a picture of McGregor crying
one of your friends sends you that and
why are you gonna look at that stupid
[__] meme a pit bull flies out of a
[__] tree when you're in a park yeah
there's so many little things that you
you know there's so many little things
yeah so when you have a oh you can't
you're with your children
you got a [__] zoo all right and all
of a sudden you have a child on the
stroller and you have a three-year-old
and he has a little doll in his hand
that a Superman whatever with a [__]
cape and he walks over to look at the
gorilla and he falls over you think as a
parent he's gonna be safe that that's
not even gonna happen in your world
right but at the same time while he's
walking over there
I call from [__] Chicago to say my
plane's delayed
and she picks up the [__] Funk
whatever there's so many different
things that can happen so as a parent
you look at that situation a lot
differently
that's the perspective that I've been
feeling the last couple of years I look
at my jokes differently now
well because when I'm with you guys I'm
with Mercy I'm really like I always look
after I always look at her and now that
you guys aren't paying attention but you
guys don't seem as worried as I do
so do you think maybe like a certain
point parents kind of get like not lazy
but like not lazy but you just trust the
environment right you know when you come
over we're in the [__] apartment more
over inside the fence
somebody has to come jump the [__]
fence if they want any problems or it's
like the food well again if you're out
in the park or something right when I'm
in a park with her I have my honor yeah
I look at the surrounding areas and I
have my other I have mine on the street
you know first off I see the move coming
10 minutes before anybody in the studio
city you'll see the [__] move
all right I see the move coming I see
the setup the whole [__] thing I see
the whole a year ago
my wife came home
and she's telling a story about a
horrible situation that happened at some
Park in Van Nuys
that the [__] the parents were
divorced or some [__] and they couldn't
see the kid the parents the father
couldn't see the child so they were at
the park
so some kid all of a sudden started
puking the parents went to help that kid
and the father fell out of a tree and
snatched the kid and started running
away and I go you fell for the [__]
the kids started having an epileptic fit
and I told my wife you fell for the
Alka-Seltzer trick
they paid that kid twenty dollars to eat
out the salsa and throw your attention
off then the kid's father ran and took
the [__] kid at the park this is a
true story I'm not making this [__] up
and I go you know again this is I go
what did you do and my wife's like I ran
over to the [__] kid I go you fell
for the alka-selves in the mouth [__]
routine I go you want to run over to
that kid you got to grab Mercy by the
[__] neck and run over there
if not they're gonna snatch your [__]
child
yeah yeah you know you gotta watch your
[__] kid man I I can't remember where
it was but there was a kid at a daycare
who went to a park and the daycare just
forgot about them they missed count and
he was like just wandering around the
park
I went from Jersey to Philadelphia to
watch The Nutcracker Suite and to go to
Betsy Ross's [__] house
High School on a bus and then if we
behaved ourselves they took us to
Callahan's [__] hamburgers and french
fries and the Yoo-hoo and [__] okay let
me explain something to you number one I
wouldn't want my mom on that trip
and number two in those days I don't
think my mom would want to be on that
trip
I think of my daughter going on field
trips and the first thing I think is I'm
on that bus with those [__] kids yeah
or in the car behind them three cars
behind us with two [__] girl isn't it
gone it's not even official y'all just
listen to Snoop Dogg oh yeah I got my
eye on you though
Mr Diaz are you a chaperone no I'm just
here I just can't imagine I just don't
see it in my world I don't see how right
now in 14 years I'm gonna [__] send
them to a summer camp yeah for six weeks
to learn how to play the piano I can't
not in today's [__] world
I was lucky because you know Lynn my
wife was always there to you know
participate in all that stuff while I
was out grinding she was she was there
you know able to do some of that stuff
so I I definitely know Lynn Lynn was
doing it a lot more than I was
I'm not laughing at the story I'm
laughing because you're not talking it's
wonderful
there's two things that give Lee anxiety
if he first is least Jewish if he goes
to the ATM and it's not working he has
that side that's number one they gotta
talking to the mic okay when Lee smokes
pot and they put on like Black Sabbath
or the cause or something it's anxiety
yeah
all right you're all right oh you see
him jiggling
I thought he was having a seizure that
he figures out he's going to fix it and
he tries to figure out how to get your
voice
oh
that's the new game when people come on
I'm gonna listen yeah
oh my God
every time I can see that something's
not right
by his body movement I can see that
something may [__] right though
[Laughter]
we got Shell Shocked this afternoon by
the way yeah you have the video for them
uh yeah sure play the video for
Edgewater is the coach Lee got Shell
Shocked this afternoon like I said we
came over here today and meet Aaron from
Obsession Labs he brought us some Vapors
to try out and whatnot
so it was mid-afternoon I had meetings
I did a little Kettlebell workout you
know I hadn't done no weights in a week
because you can't lift weights with the
[__] stitches in your nose right so I
said it's a nice day out let me go
outside and get some vitamin D and
over here with our friend John salami
and we're hanging out over here we
decided to do it for bondage all of a
sudden we decide you weren't decided
that long ago stop it so we're sitting
here running our own business and Lee
gets jazzed up he does a bunker yes this
is the bong of the week okay watch this
this is as good that we going we're
going 20 different pages here
look at this poor kid what happened this
afternoon he's as tough as Nails listen
I picked this kid out of the [__]
choir you understand me
this kid smoked pot one time out of a
can he became the producer of the show
and he became a [__] Savage believe
what's going on here you're hitting all
these buttons you're making me nervous
don't make me get that just to pick off
the microphone again [__]
you say you make me laugh so [__]
much that's pretty much it
and the spit at the ends
it's like 30 seconds later he spit
with his lungs
and it just kept going I've been there
I've been there were you just take a
good hit or something high altitude like
in Colorado
you take a hit of that [__] reefer
sometimes and all of a sudden it just
expands in your lungs you get chills and
[__] your bones get wet
I gotta tell you something man I uh when
I heard Anderson was fighting the last
fight I got excited because I know what
it's like to
to get like a Cinderella story and in my
heart I thought he had a [__]
tremendous chance like I really [__]
did man I I did too I I believed it too
you know uh and uh
you know I I I I believe that when
Anderson uh when Anderson was happy he
was happy and excited he was [__]
loose he was loose excited and happy to
fight and uh when he's like that I think
he's he's very very dangerous I think
he's a dangerous fight for anybody you
know when he when he's
feeling like that and I think he's a
dangerous fight he could be a dangerous
fight for anybody
he was so relaxed and I kept thinking
about stand-up comedy how
the more relaxed you are before you go
on stage the better you'll do
yeah oh yeah when you're unconscious is
the best that you'll do
you know that's what I call the state of
being unconscious I used to sell [__] on
the phones
in the mid 90s when I got into com I
used to sell sports information on the
phones and I would have my best
Saturdays and Sundays are your best days
you have college football college you
know football NFL
best days on paper
were the days that I stayed up till six
in the morning doing blow and not
sleeping
when I go in there at seven I'd go in
there coming down off battery acid but
from 7 to 12. I didn't really know what
I was saying
so I would go back to basics
I would read the script I would go back
to basics
and it's just the same way we commonly
the same way with fighting so if you're
a fighter
and I'm thinking about you know what
Daniel Cormier has a great
hook
great yeah left hook and a great
takedown I'm just saying off the top of
my head
and if you go in there worrying about
that guess what you're gonna get taken
down you're gonna get hit with that hook
because you're too worried about it
but if you go in there and you don't
think about it I used to go on stage and
before I go on stage I look at the
audience
ten years ago if I saw somebody with
white hair in the audience I would [__]
my pants
so I would worry about that one couple
that were 15 years older than the rest
of the crowd I really would
I would worry about them and I would go
out there and bomb because I was worried
about them
so the same thing happens when you fight
when you go into a fight if
I'm gonna tell you who went into a
[__] fight and and really you could
see that the fight was one off Drilling
when Holly Holmes beat around the Rousey
yeah
you know they put her in those positions
a thousand times
every time you touch you feel that hit
yeah grabbing the hip you drop the hips
next to all those little things were
drilled in your mind because you did
them perfect every time
so she cleansed her mind the wall of her
fears of all of anything that that that
what's in there it was like she had an
answer for it she had an answer she had
an answer when you worry about that [__]
is when you get taken down yeah
totally and it doesn't make sense but it
makes sense as a comedian and then when
I see it happen
I see that it happened it crosses over
into all the other Hearts right when you
go up on that stage when I go up on that
stage
those nights when I go on a store with
you and on the way down Laurel Canyon we
eat [__] three stars and we're
giggling and we're beeping at people
walking down Laurel Canyon by the time
I'm making them loose already
the place is sold out and I have nothing
to worry about I'm at The Comedy Store
the guy in front of me just killed
if I go up there thinking about the guy
in front of me killing I'm gonna die
so as soon as my foot hits my right foot
hits that [__] stage
I don't even think about that
[__] if I go up there and
acknowledge that guy and let the
audience acknowledge Him I will lose
that [__] round
but if I go up there like a steamroller
how you see me go up at The Comedy Store
and not give a [__] if Jesus brought me
up
like I don't give a [__] if Jesus
brought me up if Jesus just ended this
show with a magic trick and shot himself
it doesn't matter I'm still gonna rip
this [__] room apart you understand
me that's when you when you're the most
effective as an artist I just felt that
and that night I could see he was very
loose he didn't [__] around his kicks
were flowing you know what I'm saying
and and he didn't you know he he was
smart he didn't fight the takedown he
you know he went down there and showed
probably one of the best defensive
guards anybody's ever shown in mixed
martial arts I mean to have Dan Cormier
being 30 pounds heavier than you on top
of you for three rounds and Anderson
you know yeah he got a he got hit a few
times but pretty much he walked away you
know little bumps and bruises nothing
too major in comparison to what Dan
Cormier has been able to do at
heavyweight into other people Anderson's
a middleweight
the weird thing was I was watching it
with a 10th Planet student
and the 10th Planet kept going lock down
lockdown right now you sweep into an
electric gentleman listen first of all
that's a dude that's 20 pounds heavier
and he's an Olympic [__] wrestler
he's an only progressor you ain't
sweeping that [__] dude and this is
lucky to have him when he asked me yeah
no no he's got him no uh none of that
man no it was none of that so people
just didn't really understand this is a
fight you know I mean he really held him
and controlled him like I said he took a
couple shots but he didn't Mount them he
could have mounted him and [__] beat
the [__] out of him and that's where I'm
a firm believer at the end when I'm
looking at a fight
when I'm looking at a fight the last
thing I look at is how many years
experience he has as a jiu jitsu guy do
you know that really
I swear to God
I look at that as the highest
I think of something I think about
something that was very interesting
in the press conference they did in
torment so Redondo Beach at the [__]
UFC Gym Diaz showed up on McGregor what
was McGregor saying today Diaz does
anybody remember what he was saying to
him look at you
hey you you you do magic tricks
teaching kids Jiu Jitsu on Sunday class
yeah are you [__] kidding me
just that statement came back
I knew right there that statement was a
mistake he didn't see how bad of a
statement that was when he made it
I respect
my two respects as a wrestler and a jiu
jitsu guy and listen we've been all
striking since we were [__] two
there's Sensational Strikers but in the
UFC Gonzaga hits you with a good punch I
don't give a [__] who you are you're
gonna have brain damage like cyborg
you're gonna have a headache for two
[__] weeks and that was crazy
that's the strength of where we're going
now that's going to be the next level
that's going to be the next level we're
going to start caving [__] heads the
audience gonna love it the audience is
gonna love it [__] this guy's that
brain got hit like they're gonna love it
that's the first of many but uh
the [__] were we talking about I have no
idea you see what happens
I'm over here smoking dope with Leah two
in the afternoon Lee's looking at me he
don't know what the [__] I'm talking
about yeah
I don't I have no idea what it's um
nobody going back to what you were
saying no I know about the Jujitsu okay
I swear to Godly because I know ever
since I joined Jujitsu I see how good
the black belts are especially when I
used to get on top of guys in the
beginning and I'd see what they do to me
within three minutes they figured out a
way to get me off of them and they'd say
drop your weight drop your hips on my
shoulder go oh go go and I get here
I could hear him on let me go there I'm
breathing heavy and I'm like are you
okay come on we don't need to do this no
no no just give me a minute
and all of a sudden they turn a little
bit and they grab a leg and they grab
some leverage and often Joey Diaz will
go flying and I'm 100 pounds heavier
than the [__] black belt yeah so I I
gave that a lot of respect man it's like
they say this it's what's the guy's name
from Married With Children
he was a neighbor or something one of
the gray Seasons yeah I I don't know how
he is but he's a black belt right he
walked in there and the guy goes get on
top of me
ah come on I have no clothes on yeah
just get on Tommy put your weight come
on heavy heavy heavy you ready yeah
how'd you do that that's Jiu Jitsu and
but for some reason I give that 10 year
Mark of jiu jitsu
get down a lot of credit that's like a
seal like 10 years is a black belt or
just 10 years of jujitsu just I give 10
years as Jiu-Jitsu a lot never mind when
you have a black belt with some [__]
Coral stripes on it
and you've trained and you know what you
do a lot you talk a lot of [__] about
Nate Diaz he's a little crazy unorthodox
but if it's one thing that kid knows his
Jiu-Jitsu yeah because they're Gym Rats
that's what they [__] do I see that
Alberto cranes
that when I leave there's 10 kids on the
mat still and they said if you come back
at four they'll still be there they'll
still be there if you go back to the
night class they'll still be there and
those kids will go after the biggest
dudes the guys oh my God they want to
get beat up they want to go in there
they're like come on Joey get on top
they pull God on me and I'm like what
the [__] are you doing and I go to Neon
belly and I hear them
I hear your intestines I hate your whole
central nervous system and all of a
sudden I'm they got me in the [__]
single yeah and I'm going backwards man
and I love it I [__] love it so
because of that I give that specific
uh I give that specific uh discipline
when not when you two guys are gonna
fight I look at that and I give it and I
also give the wrestling aspect
because I know if he gets on top but I
can't lie to you I lean to Jujitsu a
little more because the last thing a
wrestler wants to do is be on his back
right a Jiu-Jitsu guy lives on his
[__] back
that's their [__] world Jack yeah and
if a wrestler I mean
you know the wrestler just has to worry
about defending the submission that's
mainly what the wrestler has to worry
about
but they have they normally have a good
base and uh it's much harder for the the
Jiu Jitsu guy if a guy like Cormier is
on top of you I mean I thought Anderson
you know moved his hips and la and
protected himself very very well uh you
know I mean I mean to me he showed some
of the best defensive guard I've ever
seen in somebody I mean tell me anybody
else if they would have had Dan Cormier
on top of them for
12 minutes
you know tell me what they would look
like Anthony Johnson didn't do well with
Corey no no he didn't Lee Johnson didn't
do well that's a complete different
[__] game that's a complete total
game
and I remember having this
conversation's restaurant
with Eddie Bravo and Eddie Bramble
telling me 10 years ago I knew nothing
about nothing
any problem telling me look at something
like GSP
people better get ready Jiu Jitsu they
may get that replica I've known because
once these wrestlers that's their world
yeah but if you get them on their back
it's a completely different [__]
situation they're like a turtle on their
back it's a complete different situation
I never really wrestled so I don't know
how that discipline works but like I
said to you I look at Jujitsu when I
really when I look at the Foo Fighters
and you're going yeah yeah Joey before
you said striking yeah I've seen a lot
of guys get knocked the [__] out to the
Jiu-Jitsu guys great Jiu-Jitsu guys get
knocked the [__] out
but I've also another little Jiu Jitsu
guy could weather a storm
your [__] history yeah and you lean
an inch over I mean when you when you go
back to the the whole reason why the UFC
was created was to prove that Gracie Jiu
Jitsu was the most efficient martial art
in the world and and it was proven yeah
you could get caught by a punch but you
know when you look at the odds and they
say whatever it is 90 or 80 of the
fights go to the ground if you're going
to go to the ground you better know Jiu
Jitsu and and that was proof and that's
why I mean when the UFC was created by
Horry and Gracie that's what it was for
was to prove that Gracie Jiu Jitsu was
the most efficient martial art in the
world and I believe that that was proven
you know then they started realizing
that they had to put time limits and all
that but in a street fight there's no
time limits if they're in that and
that's why you know the UFC was created
it was never really when you think about
it was never created to be a sport it
was created to show that Gracie Jiu
Jitsu was the most efficient martial art
in the world
and they would just [__] tackle any
of these guys big [__] black dudes
see in the beginning I mean you know
when I first turned it on I got to be
honest with you it wasn't for me really
it wasn't for me I liked it from the
first one no it was disgusting
what are you talking about it was the
worst thing I think I ever saw in my
life I'd rather go to Barnum and Bailey
Circus and get the Olympics get kicked
I mean I think the sport I think the
sport has improved but I'm I mean I
can't remember how how good I mean the
people tripped out on how many people
wanted to watch it you know they tried
to they tried to Outlaw it man you know
what I mean you couldn't when you think
about what what the UFC has done man
what Dana and Lorenzo have done I mean
it's absolutely incredible
I mean I mean think about like how much
how far it's came in such a short amount
of time you know people people are you
know sometimes I hear you know listen
thank God that the UFC was in their
hands because at the end of the day
those guys were true fans of the sport
Lorenzo Lorenzo didn't you know he he
did it because he of course
if it's a business they're gonna try to
make money at it but I'm just saying in
the beginning there wasn't money they
were losing money and they still wanted
to see this sport grow and to think that
in 15 years they got a sport that was
basically illegal legal in all 50 states
and be able to build what they build
it's like it's pretty incredible to see
how fast this sport has got how quick
it's gone in such a short amount of time
it's Sensational you know and I tell
people all the time I don't know how
long if it's all right so 93 you know
what I'm doing in 93 I'm becoming a
[__] comedian
I mean I'm becoming a comedian but still
at the same time I came from the Bruce
Lee era I used to remember Chinese
connection coming out in the movie
theater I still remember joining a kung
fu school
I still remember running the streets
with a [__] gear you know with with
the whole karate class in New York City
oh yeah you know I remember all this
[__] so one day yeah I'm scrolling to
the [__] channels in 1996 or
something and somebody says to me you
ever watch this this UFC and I'm looking
at and I see a guy bigger than me
with a wrestling suit on
fighting a black dude with a karate suit
on and I'm like no
it just looked like a [__] circus
showing to me at that time I grew up in
a time when
uh once a year Aaron something Aaron
something would do a promotion at
Madison Square Garden and it was 12
hours of martial arts
and it was every style and people would
fight and Spar but it was a couple kicks
to the head there was no wrestling
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu was the farthest
[__] thing from New York City at that
time there was a couple Brazilians but
normally the [__] Jiu Jitsu in New
York what's his name how to drive
four hours when he first started Jiu
Jitsu who
Matt Sarah from Long Island to down to
the Jersey Shore because there was a guy
there that taught on Sundays
on Sundays he [__] taught
that's crazy so you understand the
growth of Jiu Jitsu at the same time in
the States on Sundays he would teach in
Red Bank New Jersey
that Matt Sarah would take a [__] bus
and he goes it sucked because you only
trained for three hours
so it sucked to go all the way down
there for four
and then [__] just train for three we
wanted to go for six and then at least
take the bus ride home you can sleep and
[__] you know can you imagine that in
the New York metropolitan area well you
know the the the the cool thing is one
time you gotta have uh you know my my
business partner George on uh on your
podcast because you know he moved here
with Horry and Gracie in the late 70s to
spread the word of Jiu Jitsu and spread
you know and and some of the stories
that that Georgia tell me about those
days of like you know horian going to
you know them going to uh seminars and
you know there'd be some Kung Fu seminar
and then you know he they would sit
through the whole seminar and then at
the end of the day is there any
questions you know and then and then
horian was you know George said man he'd
see Orion raise his hand and George
would say oh [__] man what's he gonna do
now and then you go hey I have a
question what if somebody grabbed you
like this
and he goes well what do you mean he
goes well let me show you and then you
grab the guy and the guy couldn't get
out of it
and then he goes that grabbed me like
that
and then you grab him and then you you
know get out of the boom there was like
wow
and it was just so like
genius when you think about it I mean
that's like guerrilla marketing at its
greatest I mean and and then when you
think about the whole challenge of the
Gracie challenge of having people I mean
that's why the UFC was created I mean
it's actually it's a pretty cool story
you know what I mean it's pretty
incredible I was glad to see at UFC 200
Horry and Gracie being in the crowd you
know what I mean at the end of the day
he it was his idea who created this
granted the sport today is much
different than what he started
um but but at the end of the day he he
was the guy that created the Ultimate
Fighting Championship
no I knew they did something like that
that was which I think was brilliant you
know I heard of the whole Redondo beats
take over in the garage oh man it was on
Van Horn Street
it was it was it was crazy and now it's
there's a Jiu-Jitsu school in Burbank on
every four [__] box
yeah it it's just a school in North
Hollywood on every eight blocks yeah you
know it's growth the growth and that's
why sometimes you know people you know
you could say whatever you want but I
feel that everybody that has a Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu School here in the United
States in a roundabout ways It's gotta
take their hat off and give uh you know
horian a thank you you know I mean
because granted each school has
developed and they've taught different
styles of Jiu Jitsu or different
techniques that Jiu Jitsu but at the end
of the day Horry and Gracie was the guy
who brought Jiu Jitsu to America and and
nobody knew about Jiu Jitsu back then
and they started in the garage
no I remember voice I remember I was a
nightclub promoter and hoist would show
up at our clubs and I would you know me
being Brazilian I grew up in the area so
I spoke Portuguese so when the
Brazilians would get here I always if I
met him you know I was speaking
Portuguese and and I can remember joking
with toys saying hey man that Jiu Jitsu
[__] doesn't doesn't work around here
and he would just laughs yeah yeah yeah
just messing around but he's always
super nice guy and the next thing you
know I see him fighting in the UFC it
was incredible
and the whole thing that why they you
know all the different things of
choosing hoists I mean there is a family
of killers there was you know Hicks and
and oh and you know Hicks and you know
yoked up you know bigger and they they
chose hoist to show that you know it's
not about huge muscle and strength I
mean look at it you look at a guy like
hoyce he was what six one 170 pounds 173
pounds back then and just a lanky guy
you know it just seemed like any other
guy walking down the street and then
they put him in an octagon with these
huge animals and hoist comes out winning
you know shows the efficiency of Gracie
Jiu Jitsu
and I was always impressed with it I
just didn't at that time I like
Jiu-Jitsu watching it I didn't want to
touch men's feet you didn't understand
it no no no I understood it I don't want
to touch men's feet
Yes in my face
been sweating on me you know like I told
you I came from Cuba and two years later
this Chinese guys beating up people
having a [__] steak house and then
his biggest movies coming out and also
he dies so I was a brutally [__]
disciple right I was a Kung Fu guy I
found that broke down because fuja Pai
Kung Fu there was too much Mafia [__]
man so I went over with the issue karate
guys because you couldn't do it no more
you had to wear a sash and it was just
too [__] much I wanted to wear a ghee
and [__] so I went over there but I was
always a traditional karate guy and I
and when I would I would go to the store
called Honda Honda
martial arts supplies this is one black
belt in the [__] 70s Black Belt
Magazine 1973 the biggest decision
attributed for anything was Honda and it
was in Manhattan on like the seventh
floor and if you were 12 years old in
those days you go in there and come all
over yourself you buy flying stars stars
all those things that the cops carry now
they didn't carry them in the 70s that
that was all martial arts [__] with the
sticks you get any ghee you want any
association patches it wasn't like an 18
plus thing going on with the stars of
the stick well yeah but you could always
buy a man or you make your own nunchucks
you used to get changes you just get
little thick dowels I told him yeah
you get the eye hooks
with the [__] broom handle you
chopped the [__] wood yeah I would
just go to the hardware store and get
the dowels you know for the clients
you get those you cut them in half and
then you just tape it you put some uh
but then like I said when Corrado the
Hong Kong cat came out he used to put
copper
that was deep because now instead of
people walking around with bruised heads
they walked around with stitches because
you were always knock the back of your
head but new trucks came out everybody
went crazy everybody became [__]
I'm from the year of the new truck where
every half of us are [__] because we
hit ourselves in new trucks practicing
it
you would always hit your elbow your
funny bone you have no [__] idea how
it hurts the first time you did that
move to go between your legs and grab it
you hit that nut right here this move
healing bam that little piece of wood
would hit right here your whole body
would [__] rattle okay and then when
you did this one down here you would hit
yourself one time because the stick
would go like a kettlebell like the
Kettlebell the first time if you do a
kettlebell you don't know what you're
doing on the download if it lifts up
boom it hits your nutsack sorry about
that Mrs swasberg you know what I'm
saying you know what's going on in this
[__]
and then uh
seriously though why would I [__] lie
to you that would suck so all those new
checks but then there was a move
not this one at Suarez which one was it
this one
when it would clock you right here
so you would get a bump right behind the
[__] here you would hit your temple
there was one of those moves you kept
hitting behind your [__] ear which
isn't really your temple I know I'm
talking about but if you sometimes would
go here remember and then it wrapped
around the cage and then come back
sometimes if you didn't wrap it around
that's when I did oh my God you're right
in the [__] Temple right behind your
ear there you knock your balance off for
a few minutes but you stay out there in
the sun like a [__] swinging that
[__] new chair
oh
man
[Music]
no no no I I
you know I was in my own world back then
and then
I moved to L.A in Seattle somebody came
to me and then they go yeah he wants the
UFC I don't want that [__]
and I went somewhere to do comedy One
Night in one of those bars and they had
it on in the back room like on the
regular TV it wasn't on big screens yet
right people weren't playing them big
screens at bars during college football
no they were playing in the back and I
remember one day looking at it and it
just looked it looked like something I
would see at a bar
yeah but but there there was a little
bit of that in the beginning you know I
mean there there it was it was No Holds
Barred fighting you know what I'm saying
so I never no so I never got really I
never liked it when did you start liking
it
I'm hanging out with Joe Rogan they
won't shut the [__] up
they won't shut the [__] up
then he brings that other [__]
Mexican dude Eddie Bravo when they won't
shut the [__] up if it's not Jiu Jitsu
it's this [__] guy it's this [__]
guy it's that [__] guy I didn't want
to hear it no more and they would get
mad at me in those days Joe wasn't on to
do stage uncommon he was flying on
Saturday mornings there was no big way
in those days right right Joe was flying
on Savage and he'd asked me every Friday
night
talk you want to come into the UFC I'll
get you a free room
why would I want to do that
why would I want to go on to [__]
Vegas and see two Savages fight each
other that's what I thought it was that
I didn't think that they told me it was
some type of martial arts thing where's
their geese
where's their [__] head P you know
I'm saying that I just thought it was a
little too crazy
so they started
they started talking [__] about this
[__] dude that was coming to the UFC
this dude named Anderson Silva Troy went
to Joey I know
I'm the type of guy I don't like hearing
[__] don't keep telling me listen I come
to your house you make broccoli I don't
[__] like it I'm not gonna eat it
I'll eat the meat I'll eat the roast
beef I'll eat the Brazilian beef
whatever the [__] you make I'll eat I'm
not gonna touch that broccoli I don't
give a [__] if you put Garlic in it I
don't care if you're growing in your
mother's yard organically I'm not even
[__] broccoli so don't worry about it
don't keep [__] asking me don't care
I know what I am 53. I know what I
[__] want
but one night I lose the remote
you're following me I lose the remote
living room I want to take a shower I
got cats
and I lost a [__] remote and I was
watching something on what was Spike
is this first fight against leaving I'll
begin sleeping whatever I was watching
whatever I looked came into the house
when I left did you watch it live I
watched it live uh yeah June 28 2006.
and all of a sudden
I see this [__] and I go what the [__]
is that
and I waited and I called Joe the next
day and I go you got to talk to me about
this [__] guy that was amazing
because I told you I [__] told you
you love him he's [__] perfect that's
what you always talk about and when at
the end when he played the guitar and
[__] I was like oh guitar oh [__]
and then I went online I [__] learned
everything I could about them that's
and then there was a Chuck Liddell fight
that put me over the top
so it was always Chuck
and then but it was always Anderson
you know I met Anderson early on when I
met you and Chuck I didn't meet till
years later right I like Chuck also I
like Chuck's a great guy I like Chuck's
fighting stuff I liked I like this
background at that time and to know that
he was a wrestler I liked him even more
and I I like this is uh punching I liked
how he accurate he was with that [__]
punch you know Chuck had a great career
also
I liked everything about those guys I
like how they acted I liked that there
was
there were martial artists they were
martial artists I liked that there was
no insults traded
you know listen before a fight
absolutely as a man your adrenaline's up
your testosterones up
you want to agitate the opponent but I'm
not gonna go for six weeks before the
[__] fight and try to insult you but
I know it sells tickets but in my world
it goes beyond something else
[__] the tickets we're still men at the
end of the [__] week
and that's why I still like the brass
this I'm an old school guy you know what
I'm saying yeah I like Roberto Duran I
liked when he bumped at the Sugar Ray
Leonard's wife and Sugar Ray Leonard
trying to introduce his wife to him he
told him he was gonna have his wife suck
his dick and that's how he won the first
fight I love all that [__] that's
Anderson Silva simplified
you know I always said that I didn't
decide a fight till I went to the win
and nobody Justified that for me the
more than Anderson Silva which fight
especially the veto Balfour fight yeah
once we put the mask on I went and bet
Anderson Silva for 100 hours
I didn't win much but it didn't matter
because I knew just from the
psychological
of the [__] win
nothing made me go run down there listen
I'm not this guy that'll go to Vegas and
try to lose money all right I got a wife
to feed I got a three-year-old so I
don't go to Vegas to gamble to lose
money do you know when Conor McGregor
lost the fight to me
that's the way
yeah he acted when they went like this
and they flinched yeah yeah yeah yeah
boom I ran yeah yeah and then the second
that factor was a jiu jitsu black belt
but again who he rolled with and who he
got it with
and I know how those guys train
I know how those guys train and even if
that left hook is phenomenal even if he
goes backwards he's not gonna get
knocked out and you might get a little
over anxious and lean over a little bit
too much
and next thing you know you go right
back to jail son against Anderson Silva
especially when he's a guy coming up
from I mean because technically you know
he he was giving it to uh Nate but you
know being a 145 pound Guy moving up and
fighting a guy who's been fighting at
155 and 170. you know when you're 145
hitting those guys at 145 with those
punches is different than him the guy
that won 70. you know what I'm saying he
he could he he absorbed a lot of
punishment
um and was able to with you know make it
through the storm and then then it
wasn't so good for uh Conor after that
Jiu Jitsu right again I I love it I make
it such a but the punches were led to it
because he got caught right he got
caught by a punch so getting punched by
170 pounder or even 155 pounder once
again changes the this you know changed
the game a little bit and and then it
kind of goes back to even why it was so
impressive what Anderson was able to do
fighting a guy that was 30 pounds
heavier than him still being able to do
that I like in a way that they're doing
it I like that in a way that they're
missing and matching that they open
their minds to weight classes in a way
because
it let it if you're a fan
and you're really trying to learn what's
going on it really lets you know how
these Arts work how those extra 10
pounds work yeah in either direction
in either direction listen Connor could
have caught knocked them out any [__]
time totally and then it would have been
he was 20 pounds light it kind of kind
of knocked him out we saw him he had him
against the [__] ropes to get an
eyeball was broken you know the deal
what's Tony Bennett what happened you
forget about me
[Laughter]
he's on fire tonight Monday July 18th
a beautiful summer night here in
sunny in California
we gotta do a little more bonding sure
why not to let's see what we got left
over here
Jesus Christ the never-ending
let me give some shout outs here real
quick Mario fusca happy birthday the
Ortega's for 10 years now we've been
collaborating online Susan Donovan Quinn
Jim Nunya Andreas Silva old stock87 My
Little Puerto Rican broad Vanessa
borquez
and my man over on Facebook art Pawn you
bad [__]
this is crazy that
Anderson Silva's managers in the [__]
room I love all this [__] I love all
this [__] like I was gonna say no one
knows more what Conor McGregor is going
through maybe than than you because
Anderson was King of the UFC forever and
so like what when when Connor's winning
Non-Stop and he's flying around in
mansions flying around the mansions and
private jets and stuff like
how crazy does it get for him outside of
just fighting like how many distractions
do we have like how like what what is
that life like
well I mean you know I I think uh
Conor's rise was uh came much quicker
than Anderson's you know Anderson's been
in the business for a long time not I
know Conor's been fight for a long time
too but
um you know and Anderson was on top for
a lot longer right time you know I mean
so Anderson you know it's really easy to
say you know peop it's it's hard it's
hard to say people change sometimes you
know but it's difficult uh it's really
easy to say oh I would never do that or
I would never act that way
um but at the end of the day you you
really don't know what you'll act like
until you're put in that position
because if you're the baddest dude on
the planet for seven years and
everyone's walking around saying man hey
champ hey champ you're the greatest
you're the greatest you're the bad I
mean eventually you know for five seven
years people is telling you that
eventually it could probably get to your
head and you could say you know what
maybe I am you know I mean I mean we're
only human you know it's really hard to
say what you would do unless until
you're in that position to see what
you'd act like Lee you're uh
you're living at your mother's house
you're changing ties at [__]
Firestone okay from 7 30 to three they
give you every other [__] salad they
feel lucky
you know you're living downstairs in
your mother's house
your dad gave you a [__] car to drive
around and you know what but you watch
this UFC and you want to bang it out
with [__] you know
and all of a sudden you joined some jam
and you start fighting these amateur
fights and after eight fights Joe silver
bumps into you and you do the ultimate
[__] fighter
and then you go on and all those years
all those two three years four years
five years all you know is training all
you know is training and you still
change tires and Firestone
awesome the [__] UFC calls you and
you have six seven fights you start
making a little money and again you've
been training all of a sudden yeah from
time to time on Twitter some of your
body and say hey can you give an
interview on wplj and you call and you
giggle and you're you're in your
beginning stages of giving interviews
and all of a sudden boom you knock out
Michael BisMan I'm just saying and you
become the champion of the world your
life changes
that training session you were going to
go on Tuesday for your foot after the
fight to get surgery that changed they
want to talk to you on Good Morning
America
you're going to [__] New York
and on the flight to New York right now
you're going right now what when the
[__] do you think you're gonna go yeah
you're in Las Vegas you had plans to go
home the next day you didn't know you
were going to beat Holly home
you thought you were you thought you
were really going to be [__] uh Ronda
Rousey
she put her hand up on Monday morning
she was on [__] Good Morning America
yeah
what do you think she got there where
did she got there
she had to go home take a shower get
clothes and shoot the [__] New York
so she was gonna go on Tuesday
regardless whether she won a loss she
was going to go to the doctor because
she has a [__] toenail that's been
bothering her plus her back's been
tweaking her before the fight because
after a training camp there's always a
[__] Bible away there's bumps and
bruises
that all changes
now every radio station in the [__]
world
wants to talk to you Lee
not in the country in the world they
want to talk to you in China TV they
want to talk to you in Australia you
just beat Ron the [__] Rousey
what do you think happened so your life
changes completely now you get home
after 10 days guess what every
restaurant you ate at you put you a
[__] dessert Jack
somebody picked up that tab
you know what do you think happens it's
not that you get strong it's exactly
it's a [__] nightmare and now you go
back to train at the gym but guess what
the UFC publicist just sent the [__]
email
every day this week you got to do a
[__] phone tour from six to nine so
you gotta sit there by the phone and
talk to [__] people from six to nine
usually you do a strength and
conditioning
and then when the UFC camera crews are
there following you around and now you
have all that [__] now people with their
[__] camera so when you get to the
gym there's 18 people outside with
balloons and you got to take a picture
with [__] everybody that's another 30
minutes that you didn't plan on and then
if you don't you're an [__] and then
you had to pick your daughter up at
school at 3 30 but now you walked into
the gym at one but because there was 80
people there from some Foundation you
gotta [__] start trading at 145. so
that means you got a minute an hour and
15 minutes to [__] train now when do
you come back guess what you got to do
at seven you got to call into ESPN and
talk to them and talk to some chick
about what it feels like to be the
champion and how your [__] life
changed and in the meantime Dana White's
drawn opponents at you and you and your
man is just calling you and guess what
they want to sign you over at CAA they
have a project where [__] Patrick
swayzees look alike he's making a
comeback from the grave they want you to
do [__] Roadhouse you know what the
[__] do you think happens what the [__]
do you think happens and then guess what
happens now that Nike throws you 10
million [__] dollars American
you got a lawyer they cut you a check
for 40 4.2 [__] million after taxes
are paid right off the bat guess what
are you gonna get up at six in the
morning and Jog on the beach like you
used to
[__] no okay you're gonna get a track
monster and run at the [__] house
with a mask on so you're up and high
altitude you're not gonna you're gonna
work you're gonna work differently
you got to cut you got to work more
efficiently now or in your mind you got
to work more efficiently you know what
at least I had the champion and this is
so we don't like to get up early
he don't like he likes to get up at 10
and train from one to six and go eat
with his family and come back to the
camp guess what now
for a week prior to the fight not only
is he going to leave Brazil but he's got
to go to Las Vegas to do press all week
at six A.M
so now that's the what's the time
difference 82 [__] thousand hours
yeah you know you have no ideally what
the pressures are that take away from
that main floor and guess what your wife
is pregnant with Crypt with quintuplets
that [__] protein powder you drink
not only did you not test positive but
whatever it had in it [__] spermed up
your wife to have three kids there's
three kids in there right now
formulating in that [__] room and
you're in Las Vegas doing Jesus you're
doing sit-ups for Jesus but your kids
are getting [__] you know what I'm
saying there's a thousand things going
on in your mind that the person at home
does not realize
and guess what that person
that Anderson Silva that Conor McGregor
that made Diaz
no matter what it it holds on them
it tolls on you
you're healing man you have feelings you
know people sometimes people are so
inconsiderate about what they say too
they have no at the end of the day these
guys are humans you know and sometimes
people forget that yeah I mean look
we're not really seeing a long runs at
at a champion anymore
we've seen a lot of like one and done
Champions recently it's overwhelming
well and this happens in every Arena
you don't think this happened to Justin
Bieber you don't think this happens to
a musician a sports kid that came out of
the ghetto nobody ever said two words to
this [__] kid now he's the NBA's
leading scorer in every [__] station
in the world wants to talk to him
remember every Sunday we used to play
those Summer League games in Redondo
that shitty court but every Sunday you
go over and there's NBA stars playing
over there now you can't go over there
no more because they want you to be an
analyst for something all that [__]
changes you man and it takes away from a
thing called hunger Hunger is the
hardest thing to maintain that's why
when you see an Anderson Silva no matter
what you have to shake his hand because
he maintained it for so long
people are training for you and you
specifically
you have to hand it to GSP you become a
Target every everyone everyone's
training to beat you you know what I
mean you're you're the guy that everyone
wants to beat and it and it and it's
there is a lot of pressure there is a
lot of pressure with that what happened
this year in Conley
that poor girl
I don't know what happened I might hit a
pointer finger that's not my world of
Comedy but what happened to that that
girl that just did the Miller Lite
commercial with that kid what's that
girl's name everybody accused of
stealing
oh Amy Schumer right you don't think
you need that in your career
in the middle of everything's going
great now four people want to get
together and accuse you of [__] thief
that throws you off you know everything
comes back at you the media the media is
so [__] strong right now
and if you know if you watch the Conor
McGregor fight when Conor McGregor's
standing up Joe Rogan until it's kind of
better not stay on kind of got better
stay offline for two days
yeah you know can you imagine being a
fighter and going online and reading an
article by yourself
it's horrible I I mean I I I've never
had an article written I've never been a
fighter I've never fought in there but
reading the Articles or reading what
people say about Fighters that I work
with where where you have so much
love and you know commitment invested
into these guys it it offended me and
I'm not even the person that they're
talking about you know what I mean so I
could only imagine what it's like for
the actual fighter to read it you think
about Anderson I'm sorry I was just
gonna say if I was a manager or even
even with major with major sport leagues
I would tell people not to have social
media accounts
you got to help sell the fights on
social media you have to you have you
have to be a partner I mean it is sports
but it is entertainment and and that
create you have to build your brand and
and having social media social media is
such a huge part of uh of an athlete or
a celebrity's brand now that it's just
part of it man it's just you gotta you
gotta learn to balance it all and that's
why it it is a little bit it's part of
it and that's true but it's so dangerous
for them at a certain point it it must
outweigh the risks although I haven't
seen a lot of UFC fighters get in
trouble on Twitter I mean unless maybe
because
but you always attract a twit statement
you know because big big brother's
watching as they say right big brothers
[__] monitoring that [__] okay that's
what's going on
you know you think if you sign on a TV
show for NBC
if you go on there and say suck my dick
shorty you're not gonna get them [__]
Memo from the vice president
by the time you get to your [__]
thing they're gonna come to you and go
you say suck my dick Hillary on Twitter
today yes I did
you know right now CNN ABC TMZ Johnny
fonzo they're on the [__] phone they
want to talk to you about your statement
you know it's dangerous yeah it comes
back to bite in the ass well what are
you gonna do they also want you to have
it
they also require you to have listen
when you walk on a sentinel to shoot any
major TV show they give you paperwork
and that paperwork is what you're gonna
make who they're sending the check to
what size your neck is who the emergency
contact is if you get stabbed on the
[__] set you know particulars but the
last sheet
in in layman's terms it's we don't want
to be on [__] social media
everything needs to be approved to get
on social media you can't take pictures
of the set on social media blah blah
blah blah blah blah but then in a little
paragraph behind it when you read it
it's like two sentences of the saying
wink wink
like do what you have to do
well I mean I get so if you're [__]
Lisa yet and you're on a certain episode
with Brad [__] pit that's a guest
star
and Brad Pitt's right [__] there and
you take a selfie meanwhile you got a
half a million [__] people on your
Twitter and you take a picture of Brad
Pitt and you like this
they're really gonna get mad at you
you're following what I'm trying to say
to you it's like a [__] contract that
says
we don't want you on social media we
don't want you posting pictures of the
set on social media
but if it's a good picture
we'll turn around look the other if you
have over 10 000 followers yeah that's
what they're telling you so it's [__]
crazy
so listen you have to have social media
you're gonna say you're young you're
stupid somebody throws a job but you're
in social media you're a fighter you're
filled with testosterone you got a
girlfriend she's got a Twitter you gotta
answer something back what do you think
happened with big ear [__] Tupac
it was a Twitter beef okay what happened
to [__] what happened with Ice Cube
what happened
and then wa when he left my space field
they started having a [__] Feud about
music you know what I'm saying it's the
same thing only now it sounds it's on
Twitter it's on Twitter and Facebook
that's wise I know you got to drive back
I'll let you go if you got to go I'm
just gonna close up the show I'm happy
you came on tonight thanks man thank you
for being the manager of the decade for
handling the fighter with a decade in my
eyes the last performance was just great
it was awesome for a minute that Mike he
might have this [__] Everything
Changes yeah everything [__] it and
stuff until the last 10 seconds you know
I I thought at any moment he could
definitely you know he could get an
opportunity to finish the fight and I
still believe that
you know I wish somebody May so like I'm
sitting there going what if [__] man
this is silver sweeps him and submits
him with some Brazilian something
[__] crazy that nobody's ever seen in
the back of my mind I'm thinking that
I'm watching this fight I'm thinking to
myself seeing like one of the fatiguez
sitting down and somebody just
backhanded them saying what were you
thinking
and even the elbow he tried to throw if
he would have landed That Elbow
it would have been like another one of
those fricklands you know it's it's
really weird the fights that they try to
sell you and the fights that you want to
see and the fights that you really like
I couldn't wait to see no sign news
Alvarez I knew to me that was the fight
of the year I had been waiting for that
fight since they tweeted it I was like
that's me all the way I'm not even doing
comedy that night I don't give a [__]
I'm not taping I'm watching that [__]
fight you know
I don't even know what I was gonna tell
you I'm telling you these stars are
tremendous
if you want to do a weekend getaway
these Stars just to forget your [__]
memory all together
well thanks for having me thank you
brother for coming on thank you for
making it always a pleasure seeing you
yes all luck in the world with Anderson
the rest of your stable and [__] like
that
when you see my boy send them my love
tell them I think about them all the
time he's a great fighter we'll do we'll
do stay black my brother all right my
man let me just read let me get the
[__] thing there you're looking at me
like you don't know nothing look at you
tonight
you gotta stop this [__] Lee you gotta
stop coming here early you know what I'm
doing tomorrow doing two things I'm
doing the Tom Rhodes podcast but before
I do the time for roads podcast I'm
doing something I don't like doing but I
gotta do it anyway
I'm going down Indochina
indochino in Beverly Hills to get suited
for one of their suits I'm gonna wear it
on this special nice I don't know if you
guys know much about indochino let me
explain something to you
if you go to [__] Hollywood I'm the
outlet there there's those places that
you go and you buy like three Armenian
suits
499 they give you socks a shirt a belt
and a tie but you can't sit around
people because if somebody's smoking a
cigarette your suit will just
disintegrate right there it's those it's
those [__] polyester suits you can't
and I tell you like great all-purpose
suits but you want to look good and you
want to feel good and to know that you
have a nice nice suit on is a great
[__] feeling in the world okay
indochino is Reinventing men's fashion
and made to measure the suit
is the best suit you'll ever own so suda
get a one of a kind made to measure suit
okay customize the details you want you
pick the lining the lapels the personal
Monograms and more 14 unique
measurements go into making a suit that
fits you perfectly you can't go wrong
with the well-crafted hundred percent
Merino wool suit right there people can
smoke around you feel confident you
understand me also check out that made
to measure dress shirts and men's
accessories money back guarantee all
right these are suits people listen we
live in a new age no more who's got time
to go downtown get measured by a Chinese
dude pick the linen get the suit Park
walk be risk to get mugged go back up
now that shit's ended you go to a local
store you get measured you pick the suit
everything goes on file every time you
want a suit you put your [__] number
in and guess what they deliver door
nobody has to leave the house you
understand me like a [__] doctor just
in case the license invades you don't
have to get rid of another suit
anyway I'm talking to you melindo Chino
today my listeners get any premium suit
for just 399 that's up to 50 off you're
looking good you're looking sharp if you
go to court if you got to go to a
funeral if you're gonna go to a wedding
you walk in there with an indoor Chino
suit who's better than you
no one nobody tell them Lisa yeah so
what I'm gonna do is this do me a favor
go to indochino.com enter church at
checkout and I'll tell you what else I'm
gonna do shipping is great it's free
there's no reason not to try your first
custom-made suit with a deal this good
okay and I'll tell you I used to get
deals as good but the suits would never
fit me because they were stolen so you
know what you get you got to go take it
to a tailor this is [__] customized
all 14 unique measurements go into
making a suit listen to what I'm saying
to you go to indochino.com enter the
promo code Church
c-h-u-c uh hold on church
c-h-u-r-c-h for any premium suit for
just 399 and free shipping right to your
door okay there's no need no reason not
to try your first custom-made suit with
a deal this good and a suit classic from
that premium collection you'll look good
you feel good you'll be smoking you walk
in a room women will look at you and say
look at that [__] Savage of death so
so do me a favor go to indochino.com
right now
indochino.com take a look at the whole
thing how it works you're gonna [__]
love it when you buy the suit press in
church c-h-u-r-c-h
you get the suit for 399 beans that's 50
off go to indochino suit right now
listen you're sitting there like a
[__] Momo your balls are itching yeah
you don't know what the [__] to do with
your life your feet are itchy your balls
itchy it's hot you look down your
underwear are [__] disgusting okay
there's no reason to sit around like an
animal no more with disgusting underwear
you're sitting there thinking of
yourself why don't I have a woman why
doesn't nobody hit me back for match.com
because your underwear disgusting you
live in two thousand [__] six your
underwear gotta look sharp with my lying
the heads virus [__] no I'm not lying to
you all right whether you're wearing a
suit or sweats you spend 24 hours a day
in your underwear but instead of making
a statement looking good like Superman's
tight under his everyday clothes your
underwear is probably boring me undies
is here to change that number one me and
these are the most comfortable underwear
in the world why Joey because they're
made with Mo doll
m-o-h-d-a-l it's a source motor a fabric
that's twice as soft as cotton nothing
nothing can describe the FIT and feel of
me undies once you try them you'll wear
them and understand why they're called
the world's most comfortable underwear
when I go to jiu jitsu I wear me on this
why because it keeps everything dry
keeps the moisture it keeps your balls
tucked you don't have to wear a shield
you know what I'm saying that's what me
and these does sorry about that Mrs you
know me anyway and if you don't like
your first pair me undies boom they're
free no questions asked me undies has
dozens of styles and limited edition
prints to help you make a statement with
your underwear when anyone can see them
or not remember Superman listen you know
me I've been with these guys for a long
time why because their underwear are
[__] tremendous I'm a fat [__] and
they make me feel nice lean beautiful
athletic don't take it from me I'm
telling you it keeps your nut sack dry
they got plenty of styles and every
month they come out with new Styles
you're gonna love it but do me a favor
shipping is free in the US and Canada
and I'll save you up to eight dollars a
pair with a Beyond these subscription
plan get the subscription plan or a
single pair get 20 off your first order
when you go to beyondes.com Joey either
get 20 off your first order and I'll
save you up to eight dollars a pair I'm
gonna be on the subscription plan but it
all starts with gonna that's me
undies.com
Joey for twenty percent off your first
order me on these.com slash Joey that's
it guys it's all what do you want from
me
looking good that said it's over I'll
see you [__] Wednesday on it
all right tonight that's right always
remember go to honor.com right now and
press in church and get 10 off the
tremendous supply of minerals don't
forget Thursday night I'm at the
[__] Yoo-hoo room doing my
first night of the no expectations tour
I'm working on my special I don't know
what the [__] we're gonna talk about get
high come down eat some wings and take a
ride stay black see you guys tomorrow no
Wednesday
foreign